Today,
last class,
uh,
I had on the syllabus,
I think it was called a globalization
and political theory or something,
something to that effect.
And I guess since writing that,
I've changed the theme of
this final lecture a bit.
Uh,
and I want to,
I want to talk about,
uh,
defending politics or
in defense of politics.
And I'll try to explain what I mean
by that is kind of a wrap up and a
exhortation for this last class.
Uh,
in 1962,
uh,
an English political
scientists in journalist,
uh,
by the name of Bernard Crick,
wrote a short,
uh,
and very polemical and influential a
little book called in defense of politics
and by politics,
a crick mount,
a distinctive type of human activity
where conflicts of interests,
uh,
among groups are
adjudicated by discussion,
persuasion in debate,
uh,
rather than by force or by fraud.
A political society,
uh,
is crikey understood.
It is one where individuals
in groups played by certain,
agreed upon rules that will determine
how conflicts of interests are to be
decided.
And Crick called this little
book very lively and still,
uh,
definitely worth reading.
Uh,
he called his book in defense of
politics because he regarded the proper
understanding of politics is being
distorted by certain current currents of
thought and practice in his
own day among which were,
for example,
the highly ideological
style of politics found,
for example,
in the Soviet Union and its clients state,
uh,
the kinds of nationalist politics emerging
in the developing world and even in
some aspects of the conservative politics
of contemporary Britain of his time
where,
uh,
that meant a kind of unreflective
deference to customs and tradition.
I think today it's
important to try to reprise,
uh,
cricks plea for a defense of politics,
although in a slightly different way,
politics,
again as crick understood it is something
that takes place within a certain
territorially defined unit called a state.
Uh,
this may seem almost too obvious to
bear reprieve repeating for centuries,
uh,
what is called the race publica has
been regarded as the proper locus of the
citizens loyalty.
And it was thought to be the task,
uh,
of political philosophy or political
science in its original sense to teach or
to give reasons for the
love of one's own country,
classical political philosophy,
regarded patriotism as
an ennobling sentiment,
uh,
considered just a few of
the pallet following passage
passages that I had asked
Justin to put on the board from Cicero,
from Burke,
from Machiavelli,
from Rousseau,
and from Lincoln,
writers from the ancient
and the modern world,
from many different
countries and job times,
ah,
make important expressions,
uh,
some more extreme than others.
Like Machiavelli's what,
what,
what else would one
expect from an extremist,
like Machiavelli's,
just simple,
just simpler and more dignified
statements like that of Burke or Lincoln.
Uh,
but anyway,
all expressing the view that politics has
something to do with providing reasons
for the love of country,
uh,
today.
However,
uh,
the idea of patriotism a,
at least among philosophers,
seems to have fallen upon hard times.
Uh,
this isn't to say,
uh,
that patriotism is a
phenomenon of political life,
uh,
is likely to disappear to the contrary,
go drive 20 miles or so
outside of any urban area.
And one is likely to see
a flags being waived.
A bumper stickers on cars proclaiming
the drivers love of country,
a country music stations playing music
that tells us to support our troops and
keep driving our SUV.
These are signs of American
patriotism to be sure,
but,
um,
the [inaudible] but the issue seems
quite different in universities.
In an educated circles you might say,
where patriotism has come to appear to
be a morally questionable phenomenon.
Tell someone at any Ivy League University,
uh,
that you are interested in patriotism
and you will be treated as if you have
just expressed a kind of
interest in child pornography.
Uh,
raise the issue,
uh,
in one is likely to here very quickly
repeated Samuel Johnson's famous Barb,
that patriotism is the
last refuge of a scoundrel.
Uh,
or you might even hear a,
if the person's red a little bit more.
Uh,
Ian Forester's famous statement that if
he had to choose whether to betray his
friend or his country,
that he Forrester wished he had
the courage to betray his country.
Forrester,
you know,
the famous English novelist authors,
authors of Howard's and
in other important books,
uh,
foster presents the choice
between friendship over country,
uh,
of private over public goods.
It's a kind of tragic and even
noble that one has to make.
But Forrester,
Forrester in some respects,
has given us,
I would suggest a false dilemma.
Uh,
loyalty is a moral habit.
just as betrayal is a moral vice.
People who practice one,
uh,
are less likely to indulge in the other.
Consider the following example,
a few years after Forster made
his statement at Cambridge,
I believe,
three young Cambridge undergraduates in
the 1930s by the names of Kim Philby,
Donald Maclean and guide Burgess.
I don't know if those are names that
are familiar to people here any longer,
but they were very,
very famous names.
At one point.
They chose to betray their own country.
That is to say they acted for many years
as Soviet agents and for years passed
on vital secrets,
uh,
English secrets to Moscow as they
are ascended up the ladder of British
intelligence services until they were
finally exposed in the 1950s and it was
not long after they were exposed
and they had all fled to Moscow.
Uh,
did they began to betray one another.
loyalty,
it seems like betrayal a is not a bus
that one can simply get off at will rather
people who betray others
in one area of life,
uh,
are likely to do so as well in others.
So Forrester has given us a false
choice between choosing friendship over
country or country over friendship.
Uh,
indecision most matters.
I think it probably makes greater sense
to examine the problem through the
lenses of Aristotle who
tells us everything we need
to know about most questions
and the McCain ethic.
Aristotle taught us that all virtues,
that is to say,
aw excellence's of mind and heart,
uh,
are best understood as means as a
mean along a continuum of excess and
deficiency.
It is a matter of finding a balance,
the proper balance between extremes.
So it might be useful to regard patriotism
in this light if patriotism is a
virtue.
And I,
I asked the question,
if it is a,
it would be important to see it between
as a mid point between two contending
extremes,
two contending vices.
Uh,
what are these devices you
might say that obscure from us,
the meaning of the proper
meaning of the political,
uh,
today.
Uh,
on one side you could say the excess of
patriotism is a kind of nationalistic
zeal that holds absolute attachment to
one's country and one's way of life as
unconditionally good.
This is the kind of loyalty,
uh,
expressed in sentiments like,
my country,
right or wrong,
uh,
but was given powerful expression,
perhaps the most powerful expression.
Uh,
in a short book,
a,
another short book,
uh,
in this,
in this case by a German legal philosopher
of the early 20th century named Carl
Schmitt.
Carl Schmidt wrote a short book
called the concept of the political,
uh,
in 1921 and here Schmidt
drew extensively on Hobbs.
Uh,
but rather to defend a
view of the political,
but rather than tying,
uh,
the state of war,
a Hobbs is state of war to a
pre political state of nature.
Schmidt saw war and also,
which includes the preparation for war
is the inescapable condition of human
life,
uh,
of political life.
Man,
he believed is the dangerous animal
because we can kill one another and
individuals in more importantly,
groups of individuals stand to one
another in a virtually continual state of
conflict and war.
Schmidt believe hub's was
right in many important,
crucial respects,
but where he fell down was in believing
that the social contract could create a
sovereign state that
would put an end to war.
Quite the contrary.
He thought the inescapable political
fact is therefore the distinction between
what he called friend and enemy,
those who are with us and those who
are against us to misunderstand that
distinction distinction that goes all
the way back to Paula Marcus's view and
the republic where he talks about justice
being doing good to friends and harm
to enemies.
But my obviously go on much
deeper further than that.
For Schmidt.
That distinction was central to
what he called the political,
the political.
He says,
and he uses that word as a noun.
A we tend to think of political
largely is in its edge of tival farm,
but in Germany,
uh,
you all can often use
it as a noun as well.
The political he wrote is the most
intense and extreme antagonism become,
becomes that much more political.
The closer it approaches to the extreme
point that of the friend enemy grouping,
he says,
friend and enemy are the
inescapable categories through
which we experience what
he calls the political life consists
of that fundamental distinction.
Athens and Sparta,
red sox and Yankees,
Harvard and Yale,
these are fundamental groupings,
enemies,
friends and friends and enemies.
All humanitarian appeals.
He believed appeals to the concept of
human rights to free trade or so on.
All of these are,
as it were,
attempts to avoid the fundamental fact
of conflict in the need for a politics of
group solidarity.
The politics of the future he hoped
would be determined by those who have the
courage to recognize this fundamental
distinction and to act upon it.
At the other end,
however,
of the continuum of excess and deficiency,
uh,
the defect you might say of patriotism,
comes to light as a kind of today
what we might call trans political
cosmopolitanism
present gay cosmopolitanism
is two very large degree,
a product of another German philosopher
named Emmanuel Kant at writing at the
end of the 18th century.
Comte stressed on the other hand that
our moral duties and obligations respect
no national or political or other
kinds of parochial boundaries,
whatever boundaries such as race,
class,
ethnicity,
political loyalty,
and the like on this view,
on const view,
that is we oh no greater moral obligations
to fellow citizens than to any other
human beings on the face of the planet.
Citizenship,
if I can use language that is not
exactly conc owned but is largely sort of
identified with the kind of
conti and move in philosophy.
Citizenship is simply an arbitrary fact
conferred on individuals through the
accident of birth.
But since birthright citizenship
is an artifact of you,
what you might call a pure
sort of genetic lottery,
there are no moral or special
obligations attached to it.
The continent emphasis on universality.
That is to say that there is a moral
law that that can be universalized in,
held to be true for all human beings,
stressed for content that we are all
parts of what he called a kingdom of ends,
a universal kingdom of ends where every
individual is do equal moral value and
respect because simply
of their humanity alone,
that idea of a cosmopolitan
ethic of humanity can't believed,
could only be realized in a Republican
form of government today what we might
call a democracy or just speak
more precisely what con believed.
It could only hold true in a
confederation of Republics,
uh,
overseen or ruled by international law.
Current was perhaps,
I don't know if he was the first,
but he gave the first,
he gave the most powerful early expression
to the idea of a League of nations,
uh,
a League of nations that would put an
end to war altogether between states for
the sake of achieving what
he called perpetual peace.
Uh,
the title of a famous essay
of his Hobbes and Locke,
he believed were wrong in
attributing sovereignty,
uh,
absolute sovereignty to the individual
nation state for con the state,
the individual state is merely a kind of
developmental stage along the path to a
world republic,
uh,
a World Republic of states organized
around the idea of international law and
peace only in he believed a league of
republics would peace among the nations
finally be realized and would individuals
be able to treat one another as ends
rather than means?
If you don't,
if you want just some indication of
how influential costs view has been.
A,
you can think that his idea for an
international league of nations came to
fruition,
uh,
over a century after his life.
And Woodrow Wilson's famous 14 points,
uh,
issued after the first World War and
elaborated more fully in the U United
Nations Declaration of
Human Rights of 1948,
all of which bear the unmistakable
imprint of a manual count.
Now,
neither of these views,
let me argue either either of these views,
Schmidt's or cons really captures
the nature of the political.
Let me start with adequately.
So at least let me start with,
she returned to Schmidt.
Again.
Schmidt's view,
uh,
is rooted,
I believe in a very important human truth.
Namely the world is a dangerous,
in fact,
very dangerous place.
Uh,
like in many ways Hobbs or Machiavelli
Schmidt takes the extreme situation that
is to say the situation of war and
mobilization for war and turns it into the
norm,
turns it into the normal situation.
And extreme situation is
one where the very survival,
in fact,
the very independence
of society is at stake.
And for Schmidt,
every situation is potentially a life
and death struggle against a kind of
existential enemy where one must decide
to choose to choose up sides between
friends and enemies.
Politics for him is a kind of
endless struggle for power,
guided by national self interest alone.
And yet it would seem to me,
uh,
a politics of unremitting
war and preparation for war
would be have to be self
defeating.
Even Anne Schmitz own terms.
Uh,
for example,
uh,
why should the struggle
between friend and enemy,
uh,
be exclusively what might call
an inter an interstate rivalry?
Wouldn't competition between individuals
and groups just as easily become a
feature of domestic politics as well.
Why is it war?
Something that takes place exclusively
between states rather than within them is
the logic of bitter rivalry
and competition and friend
and enemy cuts all the
way,
all the way down,
so to speak.
Uh,
the logic of Schmidt's argument,
uh,
at least as I understand it,
points not only to war between states,
but ongoing civil war and
civil conflicts within states,
within between rival groups,
uh,
expressing their own desire for power
and their own loyalty to their individual
groups.
Uh,
the result of this logic of conflict,
it seems to me would be
the negation of politics.
That is to say the destruction
of the sovereign state,
uh,
as the locus of political power.
Why should,
again,
uh,
the choice of friend and enemy as choice
between states rather than individuals?
But let me then turn to console view
cosmopolitanism because if the effect of
Schmidt's distinction
between friend and enemy,
uh,
is to make politics a identical with war,
the effect of Co commenting
and cosmopolitanism,
uh,
is to confuse politics with morality.
Uh,
current in his present day followers,
uh,
wish to transcend the sovereign
state and replace it with known,
uh,
international rules of justice if Schmidt
believed that man is the dangerous
animal.
Uh,
current believes man is simply
the rule following animal,
but con desire,
it seems to me to transcend
the international to transcend
the stage with a kind
of international forum is
both naive and anti-political.
If Hobbs was right when he said that
covenants without the sword are but words,
the question is who will enforce
these international norms of justice?
[inaudible] conception of a kind of global
justice is a wish is to wish a world
without states,
a world without boundaries,
a world in short without politics,
international bodies like the United
Nations have been notoriously ineffective,
uh,
in curbing or restraining the aggressive
behavior of states and international
courts of justice like that in the Hague
have been highly selective in what they
choose to condemn.
Uh,
it would seem that reliance on such
bodies would have the further disadvantage
of uprooting people from their traditions,
from their local arrangements that most
people find as a source of reverence or
are there seems to be little room for
reverence in the sake or the sacred in the
cosmopolitan ideal.
The logic of this view,
the logic of concert view for perpetual
peace necessarily leads to a world state
world government.
Uh,
even contact admitted that a world state
would be what he called a soulless as
despotism.
He was opposed to the
idea of a world state.
But the logic of his argument leads
him in escapable in that view.
In that,
in that vein,
the under the idea underlying perpetual
peace is that human life as such human
life indepen independent that is of the
kind of life one leads is an absolute
good.
Such an idea I think can only lead
in the long run to moral decay.
That is to say to a kind of inability or
unwillingness to dedicate one's life to
ideals,
to the relatively few things that
give life wholeness and meaning.
The cosmopolitan stage would be the,
the world state would be the home
of what Nisha called the last man.
A world where nothing really matters,
where there is nothing
really of importance,
less to do a world of entertainments,
a world of fun,
uh,
world void of moral seriousness.
So these two extremes,
nationalism and cosmopolitanism are today.
The two doctrines are tendencies that
tend to obscure the true nature of the
political.
Each of these extremes contains
at best a part of the truth,
uh,
a partial truth.
Uh,
the nationalist is surely
correct in some respect.
Just see that politics,
is it always a matter of the
particular particular states,
particular nations,
particular peoples and
traditions for the nationalists,
the particular stands for something
infinitely higher and more noble than the
cosmopolitan or the universal.
We enter the world as members of a
particular family in a particular
neighborhood,
in a particular state,
in a particular part of
the country and so on.
We are a composite of particularities
and these attachments,
these particularities are not something
extraneous or accidental to our
identity,
to our identities.
They are what make us who we are.
The demand that we give up our particular
identities and assume a kind of
cosmopolitan point of view would
be the same thing to ask us,
uh,
at least to those who
are English speakers,
native English speakers,
to give up speaking English
and adopt Esperanto.
The artificial false language.
I would ask who was the
Shakespeare or Milton of Esperanto?
In other words,
everything great derives from
something rooted in particular.
This is the morality of what
you might call common ties,
but there is also some truth
and the cosmopolitan side.
On the other hand,
are we simply a determined or
condemned by the accident of birth,
a to live by the traditions
of the particular nation
in which we happen to have
been born?
Uh,
doesn't this deny what is
seems to be highest in us?
That is to say our capacity for
choice to detach ourselves from our
surroundings,
to determine for ourselves how
we will live and who we will be.
Uh,
this idea of choice,
uh,
of being able to choose for oneself is
I think at the bottom of our experience
of human dignity.
We experience our moral worth as human
beings through our ability to choose how
we will live with whom to live
and under what conditions.
This kind of ideal,
this cosmopolitan ethic has the virtue
of allowing us to stand outside of our
particular situation and view ourselves
from what you might call the standpoint
of the disinterested spectator from a
higher or more general point of view.
And clearly such a morality,
uh,
gives us a kind of critical distance
or vantage point on how we can judge
ourselves and our society
from this point of view.
Our local and particular
attachment to family,
friends,
fellow citizens again carries
no overwhelming moral weight.
We must view them as we would
view any one or anything else.
Just interestedly objectively.
And this one might call the
morality of cosmopolitanism.
Each of these,
uh,
ethics,
the ethic of communal ties,
the ethic of cosmopolitan
individualism express,
uh,
again,
an important piece of
the truth of politics,
although neither is
alone complete in itself,
how to combine them or what should we do?
Uh,
in many respect,
uh,
I think these two ethics,
these two,
these two forms of ethos are
very much combined already,
uh,
in the American regime and how the
American way of life should be properly
understood,
considered the following.
Uh,
American regime is the first truly
modern nation that has to say a nation
founded upon the principles
of modern philosophy,
our founding document,
the Charter of American liberties,
the declaration of independence
is dedicated to the
proposition that all men are
created equal.
It is fair to say that the American
regime requires more than loyalty.
That is to say,
it requires understanding.
It requires understanding of that
founding principle or that proposition,
uh,
and the various texts and debates
in which that proposition was later
articulated,
as well as the range of responses
and alternatives to it to believe,
for example,
as you all now know,
to believe that all men are created equal
and endowed with unalienable rights,
uh,
requires us to consider
the opposite proposition
contained in books like Plato's
Republic or Aristotle's politics that
believed that human beings are not equal
and that the best regime is one
governed by a philosophical aristocracy.
So to consider our regime means in some
ways to consider it in the light of
these universal alternatives.
But ours is also a regime that contains
elements of both the universal and the
particular.
Again,
the American regime is one founded on
what Jefferson called a self evident
truth.
Uh,
the truth that there are
certain unalienable rights
that these principles are
not simply true for Americans,
but believe to be good for
all human beings always and
everywhere considered Tom
pain in the rights of man.
We're t we're paying rights.
The independence of America
was accompanied by a
revolution in the principles.
And practice of government
government founded on a moral theory.
He says on the indefeasible hereditary
rights of man that is now revolving from
west to east.
In other words,
far from suggesting a traditional
form of communal morality,
uh,
American politics is pain,
suggests there requires a
commitment to the highest,
most universal moral principles that seems
to be the cosmopolitan dimension upon
which the very nature of
the American regime rests,
but the regime.
But the question does not.
And there,
the principles of Jefferson and pain,
once again,
did not arise.
Sui Generous.
Uh,
anyone knows,
uh,
Jefferson's principles about equality
and rights have their profound source.
They're profound source in
the philosophy of John Locke,
and particularly in his
second treatise of government.
Recall that lock,
uh,
occupies a central moment,
in the development of the
modern state and his idea,
new idea of a kind of industrious and
rational citizen locks philosophy emerge
not only in conversation with the
other great founders of modernity like
Machiavelli and Hobbs,
but in some important sense,
it emerge in opposition to the
tradition of the classical republic,
uh,
whose greatest representatives were Plato,
Aristotle,
Cicero,
and [inaudible].
It would seem then,
in other words,
to be an American citizen in the
fullest sense of the charm requires an
immersion,
uh,
in the philosophical tradition because
only in America of all the countries in
the world,
I believe,
does the philosophical tradition
remain most deeply and truly alive.
And yet at the same time,
uh,
the American regime requires an
understanding and appreciation,
uh,
not only for a set of abstract
philosophical ideas and debates,
but for a constitution,
it's history and a
distinctive way of life.
A regime is obviously more than a
catalog of philosophical doctrines and
abstract propositions,
but it's embedded within
a particular set of moral,
legal,
political,
constitutional practices.
They'd give it color and
distinguish it from all others.
A proper understanding of the particular
regime requires today or it requires at
any time in immersion,
in history,
not only philosophy but in
history and I mean by history,
none social history,
economic history or even cultural history,
but history in the proper sense of
the term that is political history.
Political history presupposes
the centrality of politics
of how the constitution
and of any society and its
most fundamental laws shape
the character and choices
of its citizen body.
Political history concerns the struggle
of individuals and groups for power.
It concerns the political uses of power
or maybe to speak a little more clearly
of the two great ends to
which power can be put.
Namely freedom and empire.
Political philosophy is
related to political history.
In fact,
political history or political philosophy
presupposed one another in the same
way,
in the same relation of the
universal to the particular,
whether the political philosophers
studies the principles,
the underlying principles of the regime,
the political historian examines the way
those principles have been applied in
practice or the philosopher is
concerned with the best regime,
the regime that is best according
to unchanging principles.
The historian is concerned with what
is best for a particular people at a
particular time and place.
Athenians,
Frenchmen,
uh,
Americans and so on.
And this is what the greatest
political historians,
facilities,
uh,
Theodore Momsen,
Lord Macaulay,
uh,
Henry Adams.
This is what they have done.
They have examined how different regimes
both extreme express but also depart
from fundamental principles.
When Adams,
for example,
examines in painstaking detail the
acquisition of the Louisiana territory,
uh,
under the Jefferson administration,
he does so always against the backdrop
of Jeffersonian ideals about America,
about democracy and limited government.
But that leaves us to the final question
that I want to end with is the proper
understanding and appreciation of the
political is not something we inherit,
but obviously something we must be taught.
Uh,
like anything that must be taught,
it requires teachers.
But where are such teachers to be found?
At least today,
it appears it would seem only
very rarely in universities.
Uh,
and rarer still in departments of history,
political science or economics,
excuse my a polemic.
Uh,
modern professors of history,
for example,
often appear to teach everything
but a proper respect for tradition.
Uh,
one would get the impression from many
classes that America alone among the
nations of the world is
responsible for racism,
homophobia,
the d spoilation of the planet,
and every other evil moral
evil that one can imagine.
In my own field,
political science that once designated
this skill or art possessed by the most
excellent statesmen or politician civic
education has been replaced by something
called Game Theory that regards politics
as a marketplace where individual
preferences are farmed and utilities
are maximized rather than thinking
students,
rather than teaching students to
think of themselves as citizens,
as these members,
uh,
individuals did.
The new political science treats us as
something called rational actors who
exercise our preferences.
But the question is,
what should we have a preference for?
How should rational choice be
exercised on these questions?
That is to say the most fundamental
questions are political science is sadly
silent.
Uh,
it has nothing to offer and nothing to
say by reducing our politics to choice.
And our choice to preference,
uh,
the new political science is forced to
accord legitimacy to every preference,
however vial base or in decent,
uh,
it may be that kind of value neutrality
towards preferences is akin to the
philosophic disposition
that we know as nihilism.
That is to say the belief that our
deepest principles and convictions are
nothing more than blind preferences.
So the purpose of political science,
uh,
is not to stand above or outside
the political community as a,
as an entomologist,
uh,
you know,
observing the bay ant ant behavior,
uh,
but rather to serve as a civic minded
arbitrary and guardian of disputes in
order to restore peace and stability
to conflict ridden situations,
we are in danger today of losing
touch with those questions.
And those insights,
uh,
that are the original motivation for
understanding politics and place of these
questions has arisen.
A kind of narrow minded
focus on methodology often
at the expense of the life
and death issues that make up
the substance of political,
of the political.
So I end with this question.
Uh,
what,
where should this study
of political science B.
Now you have sat through 13
weeks of an introductory course.
Where do you go from here?
Uh,
to ask a question posed
brilliantly by Karl Marx,
he asked who will educate the educators?
Uh,
the best question he ever asked,
how can we begin a comprehensive
reeducation of today's political science?
The only answer and the best answer I
can give you today is simply to read old
books.
These are our best teachers in a world
where real teachers are in short supply.
In addition to what you have read here,
uh,
I would include front and center and
your future reading books like Plato's
laws,
Machiavelli's discourses on Livy and
Monto skews in comparable spirit of the
laws.
And of course the federalist papers to
read these books in the spirit in which
they were written is to acquire an
education in political responsibility.
This,
of course are these should be supplemented
by a study of the deeds and writings
of the most important American
statesman from Jefferson,
Madison Lincoln through
Wilson and Roosevelt.
And these interns should be,
should be supported by this study of our
leading jurisprudential thinkers from
Marshall homes,
Brandeis and Frankfurter.
And finally,
this should be completed by an examination
of the most important statesman and
leaders from world history
from around the world,
from paraclese to Churchill.
Once you have completed those readings,
once you have done that.
And I would say only
when you have done that,
can you say that you are living up to
the highest offices of a Yale student?
Uh,
s aptly summarized,
uh,
a neat,
memorial gate outside of Branford College,
which says,
for God,
for country and for Yale.
Thank you for your time and
patients over this semester.
And good luck to you in the future.
[inaudible].